it's not about what Bitcoin is worth
versus gold it's what this entire world
that's predicated on the Bitcoin code
what is that gonna be worth
and I think that you know you have
Bitcoin at the core
but then all these other things being
built on top I mean it could be why not
30 50 trillion I mean I you know you can
make up a number and so here we are at
the end of the bear phase
1.7 trillion dollars in value
um is captured in this world it's not
going to zero it's not going away
foreign
guys bang bang Dan is back Dan there's a
ton to talk about I thought a great
place to start would be on the cracks in
the Legacy system before we get into
Bitcoin cryptocurrencies digital assets
and the future and that side of the
financial world in the Legacy system
we've seen banking crisis High inflation
interest rates exploding 500 plus
percent how do you evaluate where are we
right now in that system is it
sustainable will there be some big crash
what the hell is going on
yeah hey Pop great to be here
um what the hell is going on uh I would
say
um we've already had that crash you know
I I think that the uh blow up in the
banking system uh was pretty serious the
the FED as you know and the authorities
will just call them generally
um basically
you know said to the banks you can Mark
to Market your treasuries at par and
lend against them and they were all at
70 cents on the dollar so that's a huge
potential injection of liquidity it
hasn't hit the system yet but it has and
I think that was one of the reasons we
had that big bump up in gold and then uh
in Bitcoin of course as well and and eth
and some of the other uh
cryptocurrencies because liquidity
um the market sensing liquidity is going
to be plentiful again and of course
every interest rate cycle has peaked
with some sort of you know debacle
banking debacle I mean in in 94 he had
Orange County and then uh Mexico uh
blowing up uh that was the at the time I
remember that was the biggest Bond
sell-off since 1929.
um this this kind of reminds me more of
that but these guys just you know they
weren't portfolio managers uh they're
not hedge fund managers their job isn't
really to you know I would say
get the markets right and they made a
Bad Bet and it was just sort of like
Orange County and they blew up but there
was systemic risk there and The
Regulators weren't on top of it I mean I
think it was very clear to certainly
everyone under 35 and like you know more
of the crypto crowd that talk about like
failed oversight you know we always hear
about all the regulation that's needed
in the crypto space and yet you know the
banking space is heavily regulated uh
and basically suffered a run and so I
mean it's been my view for a little
while the interest rates have peaked
that they were going to Peak in sort of
Q4 q1 and
um I suspect Even If the Fed decides to
raise again uh it's not really going to
matter uh the 10-year is telling you uh
where things are I mean 10 years down at
3 40. I suspect this year
um given the backdrop we're going to
have lower growth and lower inflation
every quarter for the rest of the year
and I can see the tenure down the two
and a half or lower and the FED may ease
they may not they may stay stubborn but
I think that's why the Market's rallying
right NASDAQ gold Bitcoin heat
um they're looking out you know 12 18
months and I think there's a high degree
of confidence that this uh tightening
will be uh reversed so when you look
when you look at what's occurred we
basically saw uh rates go from zero to
five percent we saw a couple hundred
billion dollars come off the fed's
balance sheet and inflation according to
the headline CPI number never has fallen
below five percent we've been at you
know five plus percent pretty much since
I think it was like June of 21 and so we
now are going on nearly two years of
above five percent inflation and if
there is some sort of pause if there's
some sort of pivot from the FED should
we expect higher inflation or is that
headline CPI number a little bit
misleading and maybe we actually have
the real inflation number right now is
lower than what headline is telling us
well I think the forward inflation
number is lower I think that six months
from now so we had CPI headlines today
at five pretty sure six months from now
it's going to be significantly lower
potentially than below four
um and maybe below three
um and it's just that the leading
indicators all the leading macro
indicators that you know macro guys like
me have looked at for many many years
are all pointing with a very high degree
of confidence lower and the Federal
Reserve has ignored that I think they
over tightened they didn't need to
tighten as much as they did and look
even they say policy works with a lack
and I guess they sort of forgot about
that or
um you know but this is the first time
in in my career that I can remember that
the FED
um has made policy based on the two most
lagging indicators which is headline CPI
and the unemployment rate so everything
else that's leading or coincident is
turning down so I I think there may be
some World in a few years I guess where
inflation can go back up but I think
it's firmly down
um for you know for a while now there's
folks like Barry uh sternlick and others
who believe that we may see negative
inflation in those numbers by the summer
time uh do you think that we could go as
low as to go negative or do you think we
may bottom out around kind of the two
percent fed uh mandate what are you
thinking in terms of what is that down
uh kind of uh um yeah look I mean to me
one zero minus one are all the same it's
just significantly lower inflation not
an issue so I don't think I mean I think
it's a pretty bold call by Barry uh to
make a you know a six-month call like
that it could be right I mean he's
looking at the rent data
um as you know uh they're very plugged
into the real estate market so I
wouldn't fade his comments at all I just
sometimes macro takes a little longer to
happen than you think things that are
really obvious
um you know when doing analysis don't
always plan out you know tightly
um fitting way and so he could be right
I I think maybe more towards the end of
the year
um look I think any headline number
print with four or three
um is going to be surprising to people
there's still a lot of people out there
who are expecting higher inflation I
don't know not sure why and who are
super negative on the market I don't
know if you've seen some of those
indicators
um measuring investor sentiment uh the
Merrill Lynch fund manager survey came
out with super negative
um I and I think that's sort of what's
fueling part of this rally too it's um
what's surprising to me I think is uh
folks have seen that headline number
falling but I think that there's this
like looming recession right that they
think is going to come in Q3 Q4 maybe q1
of next year I don't know if it comes I
don't know if it doesn't but if people
think that there's a recession
psychologically they're prepared for
negativity they're prepared for kind of
pain
Etc but you can actually have asset
prices increasing in value at the same
time that you've got the recession and
that may not actually be uh kind of as
aware to the average investor but one of
the data points that I've been paying
more attention to is so the the year
over year CPI number is down and it
continues to fall we hit five percent uh
recently but if we look over three and
six month periods the inflation number
is actually up and you know the three
month inflation number things up like
over three percent and so when you look
at that is that telling us that there's
just a base effect at play with that
headline number and we should maybe
actually be paying more attention to an
accelerating inflation uh in the shorter
term or is that just kind of a whole
bunch of noise and that headline number
is the only thing to focus on
well I'm not exactly sure what you're
looking at I mean if you look at three
month over three month annualized rates
of change uh that's different
um I mean that's how I would look at it
so when you say three months
um is that three month year of the year
yeah no so just like literally over the
last three months right and if you think
about like core I mean the month over
month changes yes and so if you think
about it I don't I don't think that
that's that relevant okay um month over
month data
um I never look at because it doesn't
Trend it's only the annualized data that
you that you should look at and so I
mean you look at deflators you look at
the prices component I was looking at
the uh nfib
um
um I think pricing plans have completely
collapsed I can show you a chart of this
you know later
um so a lot of the leading inflation
signals as well as the market signals
look no one is smarter than the 10-year
note right I mean I I don't you know the
markets are telling you
um and they're very convinced that
inflation is not an issue to have a 3.4
tenure right
with headline CPI 5
the market participants are pretty darn
sure that this inflation number is going
to come down dramatically so
um you know there are a lot lots of
other signs
um housing I think is is
um softening and you have the this whole
issue of people having to roll over
their mortgages their auto loans
um I mean no one is buying a house with
a mortgage rate at eight percent or
seven percent again macro works with the
lag and this fed hike you know hiking
process was the most dramatic
um certainly I've ever seen
um it felt more much more dramatic than
94 that's the only one I can think of
that was that a rapid and uh of this
size
um
so the the only thing that I would say
maybe that prevents the growth and
inflation slow down from happening as
quickly as I think is that you know
there are a lot of other
um places around the world that are
starting to pick up and I think I put on
Twitter the other day the Chinese M2
numbers I think hit 13
uh which was a high for you know the
last few years so it is possible that
other places uh around the world
um don't have the same concerns uh as
the fed and and maybe start easing up
sooner
um it's very hard now to look at sort of
global data in the aggregate I mean you
can look at Global pmis there are Global
indicators
um but the system is very leaky you know
the Chinese can do what they want and
it's not like there's a global you know
Central Bank that is keeping anyone in
line I mean it's a nice Segway in a way
into Bitcoin because you know Bitcoin is
that Global Currency that's you know
validated
um by math right it you don't need eight
guys in a room to get together in each
of the countries to agree you're never
going to get us and Europe and South
America Asia to agree on what policy
should be
um but uh with Bitcoin you don't have to
worry about that but again that's maybe
that's a cart before the horse maybe I
I'm bringing that up a little too early
but I so that's why if there's any
reason that I thought it wouldn't happen
as quickly as it is going to happen that
would be it but I still think we're just
on a a course I wouldn't just say like
recession I would just say dramatic
slowdown in growth and inflation because
recession is two back-to-back quarters
of negative GDP but people Define it
differently the GDP data you know can be
kind of swirly sometimes so so I don't
ever use the word recession
um I just call it you know a Slowdown so
when one of the things that you're
mentioning here that I think is pretty
interesting is if you take the top 10
Global central banks I remember uh kind
of the start of q1 of this year we saw
the United States continuing to take
assets off of their balance sheet at the
Federal Reserve but specifically Asian
countries in China uh they were the ones
who were pumping tons of liquidity into
the market and so there was a net gain
of liquidity globally based on those top
10 central banks even though the United
States was kind of working against the
trend there and so when you evaluate uh
kind of asset prices and their future
movements how important is the US
compared to that Global analysis right
like is it actually better to look at
the global uh net liquidity versus the
United States
yeah I mean look the bottom line is I
mean it the US is still by far uh the
largest economy in the world
um has the largest you know market cap
in total
um you know the most financialized
economy and of course most transactions
around the world are still done in in
dollars so I know the Chinese GDP has
increased a lot and gotten closer to the
U.S
um but
around the edges
uh the U.S policy will drive the world
you'd have to have the rest of the world
I think going Whole Hog the other way
right and we're not really seeing that
from Europe so Europe and the US are
approximately the same size and you
throw in Asia it's about one-third a
third a third so even if China is now
stimulating
um they've got to really do it a huge
amount to offset look I I think
I think you do have to look at both
um I don't think anyone has really
figured the answer out there
um you know the U.S is very inward
looking so I don't generally think it
looks at Global policy
um there are some countries that are
more sensitive to Global policy some
country like Australia which is very
commodity dependent but it's also still
an Anglo country uh maybe is a sign you
know you can look at that as a as a sign
of
you know the impact of global liquidity
um inflation numbers have dropped there
recently too
um it looks like their Central Bank
might be done but
uh it's it's it's a difficult puzzle to
put together I I think at the moment you
have to look who's been the most
aggressive and what's at the most
extreme and certainly U.S policy
um U.S policy has been the most extreme
so I think yeah I think you need really
a lot of offset the other way right
what I mean look the macro game really
pop is about like deciphering
when things are at extremes do they tell
us stuff about the underlying economy or
markets so most of the time when the
macro is plus one or minus one
you know it's very hard to delineate
whether it's having any impact on
anything but when we have extreme
movements like we've had in the last two
three years
um I think it just becomes a lot easier
and more important to decipher the macro
what's going on in the conversations
behind closed doors with uh with all
your billionaire friends you uh happen
to be in this like macro billionaire
Circle uh and there's a ton of folks who
are constantly thinking about inflation
interest rates now the banking crisis
I'm sure there's tons of conversation
happening when that was all going down
how much of what they are still talking
about is like I'm fearful of this thing
happening or I'm waiting for this other
shoe to drop versus now it is hey we're
getting much more into a position where
uh asset prices are going to recover and
I need to understand how to position
myself to best benefit like is it a
story of optimism yeah or is the story
of pessimism right now well I I think
it's a little bit about what you said
before which is that when you have
growth slowing down it can be very
positive for markets and so I think on
the one hand a lot of guys are pretty
levered up in the two-year note
um you know even if you're just a
traditional investor just think about it
you can get four percent in a two-year
note with zero
um essentially zero risk so risk
adjusted that's a pretty chunky return
um and you can leverage that up
significantly so I would say you're you
have a lot of guys sitting in the
two-year three or five year
um expecting the growth slowdown and
then connected to that
um you know we've already had a pretty
big correction in the NASDAQ
um and I I think a lot of guys are you
know seriously risk on and in the tech
because that that's looking out to a
place where liquidity is more plentiful
um you know 12 months from now so that's
just the the macro
the macro community and gold also has
been very sneaky here it made a new high
in a lot of foreign currencies and
Australian dollar I know you're
chuckling a little bit we had that gold
conversation uh a year or two ago I
remember but it's about to make new
highs I think it'll probably get up to
around 2 300 this year it's been pretty
darn stable and that's also a great
indication that liquidity is going to be
more forthcoming you know from the FED
in the next six to 12 months so
um I wouldn't I I also think that the
bear uh the bear face for the dollar
started that that low at around 98 in
the Euro that was it
um and the currency gold forward
interest rate markets they're all sort
of saying the same thing they're looking
at all the forward-looking indicators
that macro guys look at
when you think about gold specifically
uh yes it is up but obviously something
like Bitcoin is you know up 2x off of uh
the bottom is the relationship between
gold and Bitcoin merely you know Bitcoin
is gold uh in the digital form with more
asymmetry or how do you look at those
two assets no no Bitcoin is is much
bigger it's a much bigger thing I mean
we've talked about this a little bit
before
um gold is a store of value an
anti-dollar play and there's a physical
component to it as well which I think is
very important
um but Bitcoin and you know the Bitcoin
code in the Bitcoin Network
um is a completely new invention for the
world and I've talked about it and all
the different cryptocurrencies that are
basically variations of that code
um with different use cases different
functions
um you know it's the potential to change
the way we move value around
um the way we store value so on a
moment-to-moment basis a gold in Bitcoin
both benefit from you know positive
liquidity environment and they get hurt
in a negative liquidity environment but
um you know remember it was two two
years ago it was Tudor Jones called
Bitcoin the fastest horse remember that
whole thing
um and it will definitely be uh because
there's a lot more going on in what I
call broadly this digital asset
ecosystem
um it's not just about Bitcoin as a
store of value though I do think Bitcoin
is the most important
um you know and core part of this whole
world I mean it is that pure collateral
and you know thankfully the proof of
work
um you know still is behind it
um I think that's very important very
the security apparatus the security
function of Bitcoin is truly bulletproof
and so uh you know people in the space
who talk about Bitcoin not being
relevant or going away I I don't think
they understand markets or
um you know any you know Financial
things that being said there's a lot of
building and you talk about building
also quite a lot on some of these other
chains and ethereum
um you know has definitely achieved
Network effect certainly in my view and
you have many programmers from the
outside world
um flocking to the blockchain space and
you know they're tweaking these chains
and there are you know new use cases
um that they're coming up with and I
think some of them are entirely you know
valid and they'll be other ones that
aren't but you know aside from Bitcoin
and ethereum I think everything else is
really still more of a venture project
we don't really know yet I mean Solana I
guess was
um you know
moving to a place where maybe you know
there was going to be more development
there but at the moment it's really
Bitcoin in ethereum uh I don't know
what's your what's your sense on that we
haven't talked about this in a while I
think that Bitcoin is probably the only
asset in the entire Market that uh one
has you know institutional level
liquidity two has institutional safety
in the sense of the regulatory
environment and kind of there's no
gotchas or potential risks of
re-characterization or categorization uh
on the horizon uh and then the third
thing and actually probably one of the
most important things is uh it's the
only asset where uh there is a strong
held belief both within the community
but also even among critics that the
monetary policy will remain unchanged
right and so
um I I do think that uh we spent a lot
of time uh in kind of the Bitcoin or
crypto world uh with the infighting and
everyone's throwing mud at each other
and you know the whole thing sometimes
it's hilarious other times it's probably
a waste of time and energy but one of
the things that often goes untalked
about uh or at least not kind of shine a
light out as much as it should is that
Bitcoins uh monetary policy is fixed and
so critics will say hey it's fixed
that's a bad thing right proposal say
it's fixed that's a good thing but I
think there's agreement between both uh
the critics and and the proponents that
that fixed monetary policy is a thing
and it will remain fixed when you look
at ethereum and most other assets there
is some level of a variable monetary
policy and so again uh I think everyone
agrees right the critics and the
proponents like hey the monetary policy
is fixed so it's almost like if there's
agreement between critics and proponents
that one is fixed and one is a variable
then you really have to ask yourself
like what do I believe is the more
valuable thing over the long run for the
specific investment case that I'm trying
to make as to which asset to allocate to
et cetera now the dirty secret and you
know one that I think you you have done
a great job highlighting is like forget
your personal opinion forget my personal
opinion when institutions show up like
most of them are not stock Pickers right
they're not like oh you know what let me
go pick this one stock or this one you
know crypto asset or this one uh you
know piece of real estate and that's I'm
gonna hang my hat on that they tend to
just buy the market right and they try
to just get exposure and so if you're
only putting one percent of your assets
into uh an industry you kind of want
some Diversified exposure and so they're
gonna buy you know Bitcoin ether and
whatever else that they decide to put in
that basket and so I think that there is
a dislocation maybe between you know the
people who are in this every single day
and and they're very strong-held tribal
beliefs in a certain asset versus the
institutions show up and they're like
all right well like all you guys are
fighting with each other like that seems
crazy uh I just want like crypto
exposure right and so I think you know
the Bitcoin Community argues and says
hey if we educate them further then
they'll kind of you know see the orange
light and they'll just buy Bitcoin and
just hold that I've talked to a lot of
these institutions and they're like look
even if I 100 believe what you're saying
and and everything with Bitcoin is you
know what what it's kind of promised
there's these other assets that For
Better or Worse some of them work some
of them don't and we just want you know
kind of beta exposure because this whole
industry is so asymmetric compared to
fixed income or you know even the stock
market that anything that happens in
this industry that's positive will be a
you know kind of outlier performance for
us and it'll help our annual returns
which ultimately is you know what
they're trying to drive towards
yeah I I think it's just about how you
split that up right I mean I I think for
certainly new people it's just a you
decide what should be your split between
you know Bitcoin and eth and um then I
would say you know maybe uh you know
have a fund that's in the Venture space
and then I would say of course look for
fun that's in the growth space or you
know with you know invest in some of the
more mature companies but
um you know it just depends on your risk
of word profile why do you think Bitcoin
specifically has been you know rallying
so hard so it's about 2x up uh off of
the bottom uh from the kind of FTX
Fallout Etc uh this year it's up
somewhere in the 80 percent range uh to
start the year is that debt limit crisis
and people looking for something that's
an alternative to you know potential USD
fault is that an inflation thing is that
a trying to front run the Fed thing like
why are investors driving I don't think
this it's a default thing I think that
um first of all the only reason that it
was down I think as much was you know on
the FTX fraud
um you know it got hit and then there
were concerns about Genesis and that are
unfounded
um so I think the market got sold out
and this is one of the things I told my
investors
um was that in Q you know Q4 on the on
the announcement of that fraud ethereum
couldn't make a new low in price and
Bitcoin popped down and then popped
right back up you know I put my trading
hat on from years ago just for a second
uh that's a that's uh it's a what's
called a bullish Divergence and tells
you that the market is sold out and so
we've had a bear phase for you know for
all of 22 basically and we had the most
negative news that we could possibly
think of which is someone like SBF who
was considered you know the Wonder kid
in the space you know go from 20 billion
to a fraud in the matter of you know a
few weeks and so I think that that
that piece of negative news we are not
going to see anything more negative than
that and the fact that the markets could
hold in after that just told you it was
sold out and so you had a you know a
bunch of different things happen since
that moment
um you know you had to eat upgrade uh
also eat is also up about it's probably
up even more than 80 percent I don't
know
um you know I guess if the law it was
around yeah it's probably up they're up
about the same
um but but look the reality is the Fed
tightening was overdone and you've had
10 years drop 100 basis points so that's
positive for liquidity
um the banking crisis
it's very clear
um and I think someone on Twitter said
the money in your bank it's it's it's
not your money right like you think it's
your money but not only is it not there
it's not even yours and I just think
anyone under 35
uh who's just
you know more comfortable uh moving
around in the digital space
they don't really think of banks as part
of their life I mean I'll give you a
very perfect I'll give you a perfect
example my my daughter's uh 18 years old
she's at NYU and
um she's out there renting her first uh
apartment
and um you know it's a bit of a
complicated thing to rent your apartment
in New York Etc and they they said to
her she needs to get a bank certified
check for her first month of rent and
she said something very funny she says
you know
um
I mean I don't think she's been to a
bank
maybe ever maybe in Greenwich where she
where we where we are maybe once but she
said something very funny she says you
know Daddy I don't notice that there are
any banks in New York City
and I I said what do you mean there's
one right across the place away from
where you do yoga and so it's a silly
point in a way but people who are
younger they don't really think of banks
as part of their lives they they venmo
they have you know they you know they
may use the online banking platform but
they don't actually go to Banks it's not
you know when we were kids you know at
least certainly me you know you had your
passbook your savings account you went
to your bank you got it stamped or
whatever it is so I think the move to
bitcoin
um is very natural and I do think there
is this generational aspect to it
um where uh as time goes by and the you
know and the younger generation uh
starts to build more wealth I think they
naturally
um will go to Alternative places and for
them it's completely natural it's you
know there are two billion uh video game
people out there people who who are
Gamers that's a huge number those people
live you know online or in the metaverse
or however you want to describe it
um
so
what I'm saying is is that any time that
the banking system has a problem uh I
think people fly to bitcoin and
um we're seeing it I mean Bill coin was
built for exactly this right
so I yeah so I you know it you know go
ahead when you think about uh this you
know phenomenon how International is it
versus U.S like obviously in the United
States I've always said um I think Alex
Gladstone probably has the best way to
describe it he's like the financial
privilege right I go to the ATM they're
giving me my money I go to the bank they
give me my money if I want to send a
payment or send them a payment and I
don't worry about you know hey I didn't
exercise enough today so they're not
going to let me process my stuff I don't
worry about the government showing up
and confiscate my assets uh out of my
bank account or any of that type of
stuff uh there's a lot of countries
where people do worry about that stuff
and I saw a recent um I saw a recent
article I think it was I don't want to
be misquoted here but I think it was
Lebanon maybe it was uh turkey but there
was a guy who was doing uh about
200 million oh I'm sorry I think he was
doing 20 million dollars worth of usdc
uh transaction volume like he was like a
basically like a like a tether and usdc
uh dealer and he was doing some certain
numbers 20 million 200 million whatever
it was every single month and in that
country uh where this was happening they
want Bitcoin or they want you know some
digital dollar equivalent and so is it
the international markets that you think
will end up driving more of this
adoption in the US or do you think the
U.S that's happened I mean I don't know
what you think the number is but I've
heard sort of 85 percent of total
uh volume is done outside the U.S so I
mean I already think and certainly in
the emerging countries I mean adoption
is greatest
um there are plenty of Statistics out
there but you mentioned Lebanon but you
know Turkey Brazil all of these places
where monetary policy is questionable
and you know certainly fiscal policy as
well
um I I think there's a larger natural
group of holders of Bitcoin and eth two
and and
um you know maybe a few other ones but
it's mostly I think Bitcoin so I mean I
I
uh you know I I I don't know I think
right now I I I think it's not commonly
accepted view really and uh you know
you're seeing
um other places take the lead on you
know developing regulatory Frameworks I
mean I'm hearing something out of Europe
of course there's Dubai and Singapore
that are sort of you know leading ahead
Hong Kong has now come out and said
after China Banning it they've now said
it's okay to own some of the top
cryptocurrencies I guess that just means
you know I don't know how they're
defining it obviously it's Bitcoin and
eth
um
uh so I think that the regulatory
Frameworks are going to develop
independently and the US in this area we
know is lagging behind it's it's
unfortunate because
um the Western press but I think
especially like the journal the New York
Times the Ft
um they don't really see what's going on
in this uh in the bigger ecosystem here
that it's not in fact Bitcoin is
extremely important and has an important
you know Emerging Market use case and
store of value Etc
um but there are many new things
developing in the what I call broadly
the digital asset ecosystem
um that we didn't have three four years
ago and so for me the bear phase ended
uh in Q4 and I think people starting to
realize that plus the you know the
um uh the sign of banking distress is
just clear uh clear that if you were on
the sidelines waiting to buy your
Bitcoin at 12 000 and you're itching at
16 but you didn't do it it starts
drifting up to 18 20 22 and then you
have a banking meltdown
um you know that's easily enough to take
us back to you know where we are today
30. well when you think about that
digital asset ecosystem uh we've got
this Dae map that you all have created
and uh with this map specifically I
think there's a couple of kind of key
components that you guys have outlined
there's store value Financial Services
smart contracts blockchain security
blockchain infrastructure defy nfts how
do you evaluate which parts of those
areas you are more excited about less
excited about uh or areas where you feel
like it it's the right time to lean in
versus maybe hey six 12 months from now
it'll be the right time to lean into
that area like what's your evaluation
framework for each one of these sectors
yeah
um you know we we sort of look at things
in a traditional way this is
um 10t slash one RT The Firm that
um uh were actually doing a race for now
and we're launching July
um and you know
I I think that when I say traditionally
I mean we're looking for revenue and so
and we're looking for a business to sort
of achieve I would say you know about to
achieve escape velocity I mean we focus
on on growth equities you know I mean as
far as I know we're still the only uh
active Fund in the world out there that
exclusively focuses on uh growth equity
in the crypto blockchain space I that
that's one thing we should talk about
because I I Marvel that there aren't
more people doing it
um yeah we've invested 1.2 billion into
26 different businesses
um but we've got a pretty rigorous
process and it does revolve around you
know the business as a business I mean I
I'm not like the Venture guys who are
trying to make 100x and trying to find
the next best greatest technology uh
um you know we're our our you know
return
um expectations or I would say more
modest at least for the space you know
five to ten X over the next 10 years
um you're probably thinking like why
didn't bother with a five to ten x uh in
the space over 10 years that'll that'll
obviously happen but for a lot of our
traditional investors
um it's a way for them to dip their toe
in
um and learn about the space and you
know again we only invest in the
businesses we're not investing in in
cryptocurrency
um and I I it's not that I'm against it
it's just that many of our LPS basically
legally aren't allowed to own crypto yet
so they can own private equity and of
course many of these companies
um you know have tokens and and crypto
and Bitcoin on the balance sheet but
again we're purchasing stakes in the
equity but it's based on more
traditional metrics you know we're
looking at
um you know things that any growth
Equity Firm would look for that they've
achieved product Market fit that the
leadership you know has a vision that
you know we can be a part of the board
potentially and and help you know
Shepherd the company towards
realizations
um
you know so it's not that
um I'm making a bet that let's say nfts
are going to consume the whole space and
that's going to be the only focal area
we're building a portfolio that's
Diversified broadly
um you know between we have three
different buckets and between those
three buckets you we're gonna get uh
access to the growth in the overall
digital asset ecosystem
um and one thing I would say is that we
also look
um to the leaderships to be able to
Pivot that's a very important thing is
you know the space is growing so quickly
um even you know two three years ago
there were no nfts there was no D5 there
were no stable coins I mean it just
didn't exist and so the leadership team
is very important it's not just that
they're doing Innovative stuff it's that
can they pivot when they see an
opportunity in their area and that's um
you know just as as an example Gemini a
few years ago bought Nifty Gateway right
um and you know that was uh you know a
pivot for them and
um you know you yacht from Anna mocha is
probably the master pivoter
um you know he's you know built himself
a very large uh portfolio Venture
portfolio I I'd also say in some of our
businesses there's quite an embedded
Venture bet because they are
um you know looking to make Acquisitions
and looking to do bolt-ons Etc so
um
you know I I would just say that we're
not really betting on a chain to be
successful or a specific technology it's
more do we believe this business can go
up 10 times in value over the next 10
years and so we have like you know seven
or eight different valuation metrics we
write these 50 page investors memos etc
etc just like any traditional private
Equity Firm would do how do you think
about uh cash flow obviously most of the
tech sector has been unprofitable
there's plenty of companies that are
trading in the public markets uh from
the non-kind of crypto blockchain
digital asset industry that still have
never returned a single dollar of profit
is it something where in this industry
the companies are going to have to get
the cash flow uh positive and and
eventually go public or do you think
that we'll see a lot of these companies
end up getting out into the public
markets or getting bought before they
ever turn a dollar profit yeah I mean
you know look today
um there's only one crypto blockchain
business in the world really that's
public and that's coinbase and Galaxy to
some extent too but I'm saying very
large one is coinbase it is impossible
and you can hold me to this that five
years from now there will only be one
public crypto blockchain business it's
impossible now I don't know that they're
all going to be on NASDAQ I think
they're going to be jurisdictions that
are opening up that are super friendly
the crypto blockchain businesses
um so you might start seeing companies
uh go public in other jurisdictions I
mean you know obviously NASDAQ is the
best place the most liquid Etc
um
so uh I you know that being said I mean
just think about this for a second in
2019 when I had the idea for the fund
there were only about 25 companies in
the world in the crypto blockchain space
that had a value of let's say over 400
million all right and I remember doing a
lot of early meetings and people telling
me man there aren't enough companies for
you to invest in you know half of my
meetings were just you know telling
people look the space is going to grow
um and it's going to grow and it's going
to be big enough and today they're
probably you know I would say about 150
companies that have over a value of
around three four hundred million and
that's uh down probably from over 200
from the peak so it's an enormous
um sector
um in the you know in the private area
and I just don't see how how
um you know within the next two three
four years uh the more established ones
aren't public I mean you know Ledger for
instance I think could probably be a
public company
um you know in the next 18 24 months
certainly has the you know is um I would
say it it looks more like a traditional
company but they do very cool stuff
Ledger live they're coming out with
Stacks
um you know their core of the ecosystem
they have a virtual monopoly on Hardware
devices
um you know the Ledger live platform is
really doing super well this year
they've got a cut uh institutional
custody
um you know so Anna mocha used to be a
public company they certainly within you
know 12 to 24 months could be public I
just think that
um the outside world has yet to
you know sign off on this right the
Goldman's and Morgan stanleys aren't
rushing to bring these companies public
um I think that my fund is going to have
to get much more involved in helping
Shepard some of the companies uh to the
public Arena and to to realizations and
so I'm bringing on a few Partners now
who have that skill set and I think are
going to help
um you know help Drive uh help drive
that process so
um
you know look uh you know dare a bit is
another company
um that's doing
quite a I mean quite a large amount of
net profit I mean it's not just cash
flow
um you know they're entertaining uh
setting up in Dubai now uh they've got
90 percent of the total World Bitcoin
and ethereum options uh business I mean
you don't find businesses like this you
know in the traditional World they did
120 million in net profit last year and
almost 200 the year before so
um there are some large businesses they
don't necessarily look exactly like
large businesses from the traditional
world but they're getting there and um
I'm just surprised there aren't more as
I said to you more players uh from the
traditional World getting involved but I
just think it's it's just a matter of
time
so when you start to Think Through uh
kind of where this whole Space is going
what is you know maybe your two-year
Vision here is it Bitcoin eth other
digital assets that are liquid uh those
are higher prices you think there will
be more private companies that have gone
public and are out uh kind of
sustainable businesses there and most
institutions have exposure to the
industry or you know where where do we
stray from maybe you know those three
data points so one thing that's happened
recently that I think has taken many
people by surprise is the interest from
the traditional World in uh in
incorporating some you know aspect of
the blockchain into their business
models and you know different companies
have done different things but there's
literally there's there's news almost
every day
um you know car parts and insurance uh
Alfa Romeo
um has car parts and insurance secured
on a blockchain the McLaren I'm looking
at this Auto section we have here
Mclaren has nft collections for fan
engagement you've got the luxury
um you know area as well you've got
Sports incorporating nfts I think that's
the one surprising thing that adoption
has come from the traditional World via
um uh the growth in the nft space
so uh you know the funny one that I
always mention when I'm speaking to
investors is this I don't know if you
saw this California the Department of
Motor Vehicles did you see this thing
that
um they're going to give everybody in
California a digital wallet they're
going to have their license and the deed
to their car
um put on the teasers blockchain
um Is that real are they really gonna do
that is real yeah that's real I we
actually dug into that and um you know
it's funny even guys like us are like Is
that real is that possible
um and so I you know I I think that look
if you've got a non-economic agent like
that
um thinking in those terms
um I know I think it was a and z Bank in
Australia just uh this week has put
carbon credits uh on a blockchain and I
think they were actually traded so this
digitization you know of value uh asset
tokenization you know incorporation by
the traditional by the big companies of
somehow blockchain you read about
polygon and Starbucks obviously you know
just think back three years ago at the
end of the last bear phase we didn't
have any of this there was none of this
existed
um defy the the amount of dollars
settled in on stable coins last year was
eight trillion dollars eight trillion
dollars settled on on on unstable coins
you've got layer ones now
um you know popping up as well we didn't
have any of this before and so like when
I when I talk about the digital asset
ecosystem it's really just sort of the
broadest term that I can think of that
you know
um you know encompasses all of these
activities uh because yes there's
Bitcoin store of value impenetrable
collateral great but there there are a
zillion other things going on and um
that are leveraged off the uh you know
the initial invention as I call it I
mean yeah here I'm seeing look at this
monthly active addresses for eth polygon
Solana binance and Avalanche just hit a
record high
so like where is the bear fit right I
mean and actually they increased pretty
much throughout 22.
um stable coin business you yourself
just mentioned some guy in Lebanon is
settling is trading 20 million dollars a
month
um these things aren't going away and
there are many interesting businesses
that are growing up with all this value
that's now trading the digital sphere
and so the value of the Dae as I call it
is 1.7 trillion dollars that's the value
of all the cryptocurrencies and the
value of all the equity in the space
that was 300 billion in the middle of
19. right it was 3.5 trillion a year ago
but 1.7 trillion dollars like that's the
you know the startling thing that's the
amazing thing it's all happening
um it's just happening in all these
different sectors that I've included in
this map and our job really and what we
do is just try to get exposure to all
the growth that's happening there and
then all the potential growth
um that might happen in the future that
we're not you know even aware of just
yet so every kind of uh mini timeline in
this industry so you get kind of these
bull markets you get the Peaks you then
get the drawdowns you kind of repeat the
cycle over and over again they're all
driven by narratives they're all driven
by some sort of uh thing what are the
narratives or themes that you are
looking for you know kind of over 2023
and into 2024 there's specific things
that you guys have identified that you
either think will be areas of Interest
or kind of uh themes that you really
want to get behind
yeah I mean one thing is just you know
tokenization of of real assets and I
think that that's sort of a dream you
know everyone has talked about that one
day
um you know that's gonna happen and
there we have a little bucket there in
our in our map
um that you know we mentioned there are
only three or four companies now in the
world that are attempting it uh figure
is one you know a lot about figure and
Mike Cagney
um you know I I think uh he's sort of a
master at being able to Pivot but he's
now in a pretty good position to you
know execute on that vision and there
are a few other companies you know
security securitize I mean there there
are a few companies but it's still
really small and there isn't enough
Revenue really for us to you know to
invest there but I think over the next
12 to 24 months the it's certainly
possible
um I mean do you do you have any
thoughts about that yourself I know you
were an early investor and figure and
you've talked about you know
tokenization of real world assets
um yeah I think that my
um you know kind of view of the world is
very different than most of the people
have talked about the tokenization like
I've always thought that there's this
macro uh kind of generational Trend
right and that trend is automation
automation you know I think I've been
talking about this since maybe 2017 2018
where automation is maybe the least
controversial thing when you walk into a
room of investors yeah you know you can
be like controversial yeah you're like
hey do you think bitcoin's gonna be
higher or lower a bunch of people yell
and scream and argue with each other
right do you think that this stalker you
know this uh piece of real estate higher
or lower like they'll yell and scream at
each other if you walk in a room and
you're like do you think the world's
gonna be more automated or less
automated 10 years from now every single
person agrees more automated now maybe
that's the counter signal maybe actually
we should be scared and say like hey
that's not actually gonna happen but I
do think that uh people have this
consensus view of it well and it's more
digital or less digital correct right
that's another way to phrase it I think
you'd get everyone thinking more digital
well and I think that
um I've always looked at the automation
as just a repeat of history and so if
you think about a physical US dollar
right you could not actually use your
computer to move physical dollars you
couldn't put the dollar into the
computer and there was no ability to do
this with the internet and so you had to
electronically create dollars and so you
went from physical analog dollars to
electronic qsips now those electronic
q-sips didn't just represent dollars
they also represented stocks and uh
bonds and commodities and like all these
other things once you had the assets in
electronic q-sip format now you could
have electronic transactions and so
that's where you get kind of these one
and two day settlement times Etc now we
want to move to this like real-time
instantaneous
um you know kind of automated World well
the electronic cuset based assets can't
actually operate in that world there's a
technology kind of mismatch same thing
as trying to put the physical dollar
into the computer putting the electronic
q-sip into an automated transaction
system doesn't work and so you have to
digitize them now I think one of the
areas that ends up uh maybe I've changed
my mind on or I'm less convinced of is
is it tokenized or is it digitized and
maybe those two things are the same or
maybe they end up being different I'm
not really sure but what I do know is
that they can't be electronic Q sets
there has to be some iteration of that
technology so that we can get that
automated transactions and so what this
looks like is if you look at Bitcoin
right it is a digital currency that
digital currency allows for all sorts of
kind of automatic transactions the best
example being like streaming payments
right if I can send you a penny every
half second that's pretty cool you can't
do that with electronic Q7 right but it
also begs the question of like what else
could you do with a currency that is
digital and so there's like the example
everyone always talks about where you're
going to drive your your car down the
road and your car is going to pay the
toll automatically now it's a little bit
of a grand promise and maybe we're
already closer than we think because in
Florida if you drive your car your sun
pass which sits on your windshield
technically is paying now it's accruing
for the month you kind of paid off at
the end of the month or whatever but is
there a world where there is these
automatic transactions so the big
question and kind of think what gets
that what you're talking about here is
what other assets will get into that
digital uh kind of form factor that then
can be used for automatic transactions
and I think if you go on the extreme end
of the bowls every asset right like
they're literally like every single
thing will be digitized and everything
will be
correct yeah now on the other side the
critics are like why would you ever
digitize anything right other than you
know uh the currency and so as with most
Extremes in the world like the truth
fraud is somewhere in between where
there's more than just a currency that
will end up being digital so that it can
be used in these economic uh automated
transactions but it won't necessarily be
every single thing and I always go back
to I forget the exact numbers of the
stat now but some like portion I think
it's like close like 60 to 80 percent of
all Bond transaction in the United
States still happens over like Bloomberg
chat or telephone right like I I
remember reading some article maybe like
two or three years ago where they're
like look even though there are these
like all these digital systems like
they're still kind of chat based or
phone call based for a very large
portion of the transactions and so if
you think about that even if the
technology is available it doesn't mean
people are going to use it and so I
think that we love to just point this
like okay here's the black and white
world of the Future Let's tie a bow on
it this is exactly what it's going to
look like it's really pretty and it's
amazing the world don't doesn't act like
that right like it is way Messier it's
way more volatile and so it's very
obvious to me Bitcoin will be
um kind of an important part of that
future and it is the first you didn't
mentioned lightning I thought you were
going to mention lightning well I think
that's part of the streaming payments
and everything right it's like it's like
basically
um you know when you're able to send
things instantaneously and nearly for
free like it's kind of the idea of a
capital flows to where it's treated best
right I actually think that capital is
kind of like water as well and you maybe
you expanded like all economic value it
takes the path of least resistance and
so if something is instantaneous and
free that is likely to get much more
volume right than something that is
super high friction and so lightning
obviously is doing that for Bitcoin but
like if other assets become digitized
where will that happen and how will it
happen and I think you know one of the
things I'd love to hear your opinion on
is
um you know the Bitcoin Community has
yelled and screamed for a long time
about non-bitcoin digital assets but now
we see things like
um you know are we going to try to bring
stable coins to bitcoin are we going to
try to bring nfts to bitcoin does that
change the receptivity yeah does that
change the receptivity of the community
if like if it's a digital asset but it's
built on top of Bitcoin does that make
it okay versus not I don't have those
answers but I think these are some of
the questions now that are starting to
come up and people are trying to figure
out and there's a lot of controversy
there's a lot of debate but five years
ten years from now I think we'll have
some answers right and there'll be more
clarity in the market so what do you
think about some of that stuff in terms
of the digital assets but being built on
bitcoin versus being built elsewhere
yeah but yeah let me let me before I get
into let me just ask you one thing
because you said you know
um that uh you didn't
um you don't know whether all assets get
you know placed on a blockchain or what
whatever it is just let me ask you how
many nfts it's a trivia question how
many nfts exist in the world today
number like uh total nfts or like how
many collections total nfts oh
people are going wild in 2021 so I gotta
go with uh 1 billion okay so my analyst
who focuses on this all day every day
one trillion nfts
one trillion is the number as of like
last week now most of them are worth
zero
oh man okay so I'm just saying
it's possible
that you know
you could have some of those things
holding value I mean not
meaning as opposed to just holding like
a drawing you know or something or
whatever it is uh you know something
um I'm just like anything of that you
know that's completely irrelevant people
just minting them for fun kind of thing
so you know that's what's kind of
interesting to me that you go from zero
three years ago to a trillion like a
trillion is a big number
um
so it just shows you that the framework
is flexible right that's what I think is
incredible like what can go what else
goes to a trillion in you know two to
three years
so there is a framework there is a place
potentially for a lot of things you know
that aren't worthless so anyway I when I
heard that number that shocked me and
we're supposed to know these kinds of
things that's shocking to me right now
yeah I know I know but that is the
number
um you know ordinals and other things on
bitcoin to me
like I don't know I guess I'm a little
bit with Adam back on this whereas
Bitcoin is you know pure collateral and
you know it'd be nice to just leave it
alone and not infect it in any way
um but the reality is is you know human
beings they like to create they like to
do new things they like choices you know
the the problem I had with the the the
the the
Bitcoin like super duper only Bitcoin
people was that it just it it doesn't
reflect a human
um pattern of behavior you know it's
like saying you can only have one burger
at McDonald's and there's only going to
be one Burger well no there isn't there
are going to be lots of burgers at lots
of different places and maybe McDonald's
is the best burger but you know what I
like a competitive landscape one of the
things I like about you know the space
is that it is free of government
intervention it's free of of all really
outside intervention we haven't talked
about how incredibly the space is held
up despite you know all the debacles
that we saw last year and so you know I
like a competitive environment I want
Bitcoin to continue to have to prove
itself as the best store value why the
hell not right like it is and you know
what uh it needs to continue to prove I
mean it doesn't to me but
um so
I I'm not a programmer and
um I don't like you know obviously each
of these different chains have different
strengths and I don't see why Bitcoin
has to have you know it should focus on
security right it should be the one
thing in the world out there that will
never ever be hacked can't be hacked is
bulletproof is pure collateral I I don't
see why that's not enough
um again I am I'm a gold guy a little
bit coming from a little bit of a you
know my macro background but
um if people want to do funkier stuff on
it I and it's flexible I don't see what
the issue is
um and I think that's the same view I
have for other chains like why can't
other chains carve out some very
specific use case that works best for
them
um there's no reason why that should be
illegitimate it's just that don't think
that that's Bitcoin understand that
that's something else but that's
something else you know could be you
know valuable and um I think the nft
space especially as it pertains to
blockchain gaming
um you know is very important
um you know there are other you know
defy has its you know use case
um you know I I don't think that's going
away uh blockchain infrastructure you
know I think that has you know an
important place there are rails that
need to be built
um for
um you know proof of stake currencies
um so I I again I I thought for a while
that this digital asset ecosystem is
much bigger than people know that it's
fascinating it's complex
and that the adoption that is happening
is happening in all these different
sectors and that's really what's so
important it's not happening in one
place it's happening in so many
different places it's impossible for a
guy like me to keep track of it and I've
got six analysts and I've got you know
15 people and this whole deep team and
you know I I've got zero bandwidth just
trying to keep up with developments in
the space so that's what you know the
that the great innovation of course is
the Bitcoin code right that's that's the
genius and we all agree on that
um but humans are going to create and
adapt new things
um and I think that the space uh you
know that's why I called the fund in 19
my original thought was the space was
going to go to 10 trillion in value
that's from 300 billion it was a 30X and
10 years I think that's going to be
wrong now I think the space is probably
um you know going to go much higher than
10 trillion because it's starting to
Encompass everything right it's not just
money store of value programmable
contracts defy nfts stable coins it's
everything right tokenizing assets what
is your view on uh how big Bitcoin can
get not like a price prediction right so
I tend to think that that's uh played
out and frankly I've been saying the
same thing for a while okay and I think
it's three to five hundred thousand is a
good solid place you know given the
value of other assets sort of in the
world and I think that puts it around
around what 5 trillion or something like
that five to six trillion something like
that I think 500k would put it around 10
trillion if I remember yeah so I don't
know somewhere between five to eight
trillion
um do I think it could go to 10 sure
absolutely it absolutely can go to 10.
um in that world right in that way in
that world do you think that it will
surpass gold and that like Gold's market
cap contracts and Bitcoin expands do you
think that they both you know what kind
of store value assets become uh much
more uh sought after and so actually
gold and Bitcoin market caps expand
together like how do you kind of see see
that playing yeah look I think
eventually
um
you know gold has a physical component
and you know I you know founded this
company with my partner gbi gold bullion
International we sell and store physical
gold and I've always
um felt that that was an important
aspect of gold and people say you can't
take it with you you can't transfer you
can you can do all you can do all kinds
of things uh with gold gold is even
being tokenized now I think there's one
token that has over a billion dollars of
of gold
um that it's tokenized but that aside
um I I think that in a completely and I
think I said this on your last I
remember saying this on your last last
time we chatted was that in a world that
is you know 100 trillion digital let's
just say everything is digitized there
will be value
um for having a physical store of value
right and and I I think and it is
portable unlike real estate and other
things that that hold um that hold their
value but uh I don't really you know Pop
I think what's changed a lot in the last
two three years is that
I don't think the discussion really is
about Bitcoin and or gold anymore gold
is going to do its thing it's gonna bump
along it's not about what Bitcoin is
worth versus gold it's what this entire
world that's predicated on the Bitcoin
code what is that gonna be worth
and I think that you know you have
Bitcoin at the core
but then all these other things being
built on top I mean it could be why not
30 50 trillion I mean I you know you can
make up a number
um but what I see is we've gone through
a major bear phase and we have companies
that made more money in 22 than 21.
throughout a bear phase like that's
pretty incredible why because they're
building stuff that is needed that
there's demand for it their whole worlds
out there that are unaffected by the
Federal Reserve um do you think guys are
going to stop playing video games
because the FED raise rates do you think
they're not going to want you know to
you know Port their in-game items with
them you don't I mean it just you know
did the development of blockchain games
slow I mean no they didn't and so we
don't know necessarily you know where
you know which area is going to you know
run with a ball and going to be the
largest grower I don't even think that's
so important I think it's just important
to to have exposure to this space
generally and so here we are at the end
of the veriface
1.7 trillion dollars in value
um is captured in this world it's not
going to zero it's not going away
there's no one regulating it away uh if
the we saw what happened two years ago
remember when the Chinese banned Bitcoin
and they threw out their Bitcoin miners
nothing happened
um you know the it's it's a it's a
decentralized network of value it can't
be banned right people ask me I don't
like and is it going to be bad no
there's there's no Banning it's a thing
you can't ban the internet You Can't Ban
air or you know the Sun or whatever it
is I mean it's just ridiculous
um uh and I think it's just because the
barrier to understanding this is high
right like that map I sent you have you
ever seen anything like that before I I
haven't I've seen Market maps of like
specific segments but I haven't seen
kind of the the full thing uh right and
that's and and this is you know we do
this all day every day and I've never
seen another map like this so it's just
clearly
um like people's focal points I think
just need to be
um adjusted and um
and the the nature of the conversation I
think has to change it's not just about
let's prevent people from using Bitcoin
or you know let's prevent let's you know
let's rail against every other currency
that isn't Bitcoin or people railing
against Bitcoin that it isn't more than
a store value or whatever it is this
whole world is growing up and it's
seeping into everything and I think
that's the story I I think uh that is a
great story to uh continue telling if
people want to find you on the internet
somewhere where can we send them
well the internet well I'm a Twitter
dtab cap
um you know we also have a website that
there's the 10t website but also the one
round table partners website
um that's sort of in the making but you
know Twitter is easy right I mean you
and I like DM through Twitter
um
strangely my follower account hasn't
moved in like four months I don't know
whether the algorithm is completely
locked me out or you know who knows what
I don't know what you found there but
um uh I still use Twitter quite a lot I
find it very useful so
um I'm right there with you I I tend to
think that Twitter's algorithm a whole
bunch of stuff are getting played around
with maybe doing some tests yeah
whatever but still an amazing and
Linkedin I actually think LinkedIn has
improved a lot it's a little more
businessy and people sort of don't fly
off the handle there
um but I think LinkedIn is is very good
I I have to say it's become you know
more of a social platform as well so I'm
on LinkedIn too
I love it all right Dan I can talk to
you literally for hours I appreciate
everything you've been doing you uh are
one of the major Bridges between I think
uh kind of the macro world and uh and
this new world that we're building so I
wish that we had more people like you
but uh keep up the great work anyone who
has not uh followed you on Twitter I
highly suggested maybe we can move your
follower number up there for you no no
it's fine it's all right
I'm shocked that it is where it is but I
think they've got to be a lot of Chinese
Bots uh there still that they're weeding
out right nah I think you're doing a a
great job all right we'll definitely do
it again in the future all right thanks
Tom